السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان محمد رسول رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الفلاح حي على الفلاح
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستهديه ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد
ومن يضلل فلن تجد له وليا
مرشدا واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم
صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
والتابعين اما بعد معاشر الموحدين عباد
الله فان اصدق الكلام كلام الله عز وجل
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وان شر الامور محدثاتها وان كل محدثه بدعه
وان كل بدعه
ضلاله وان كل ضلاله في النار اسال الله
العظيم رب العرش العظيم بمنه وكرمه وعفوه
ان يجيرني واياكم منها انه ولي ذلك
والقادر
عليه اما بعد فيقول الله سبحانه وتعالى يا
ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس
واحده وخلق منها
زوجها وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام ان الله كان عليكم
رقيبا ويقول سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين
امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا تموتون الا
وانتم
مسلمون ويقول سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين
امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا قولا سديدا يصلح
لكم اعمالكم ويغفر لكم
ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما اما
بعد لا بد ان يكون معلوما لدى المسلم ان
الظلم من الاشياء التي حرم حرمها الله
سبحانه وتعالى على نفسه وجعله محرما بين
الخلائق ولما كانت حقيقه الظلم والظلم
اصطلاحا هو وضع الشيء في غير
موضعه واخفاء
الحقيقه ولما كانت حقيقه الظلم هو وضع
الشيء في غير موضعه نزه الله سبحانه
وتعالى نفسه عن الظلم حين
قال ان الله لا يظلم مثقال ذره وان تك
حسنه
يضاعفها وقال عز وجل وما ربك بظلام للعبيد
فهو سبحانه وتعالى احكم الحاكمين واعدل
العادلين وكما حرم الظلم على نفسه جل جل
في
علاه فكذلك حرمه على عباده ونهاهم ان ظالم
فيما بينهم او فيما بينهم فقد ثبت في صحيح
مسلم عن ابي ذر الغفاري رضي الله عنه عن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فيما يرويه عن
ربه عز وجل انه
قال يا عبادي اني حرمت الظلم على نفسي
وجعلته بينكم محرما فلا تظالموا يا عبادي
كلكم
ضال الا من هديته فاستهدوني اهدكم يا
عبادي كلكم جائع الا من اطعمته فاستطعموني
اطعمكم يا عبادي كلكم عار الا من كسوته
فاستكسوني اكسكم يا
عبادي انكم تخطئون بالليل والنهار وانا
اغفر الذنوب جميعا فاستغفروني اغفر لكم
يا عبادي انكم لن تبلغوا ضري فتضروني ولن
تبلغوا نفعي ف
فتنفعوني يا عبادي لو ان اولكم
واخركم وانسكم وجنكم كانوا على اتقى قلب
رجل واحد
منكم ما زاد ذلك في ملك شيئا يا عبادي لو
ان اولكم واخركم وانسكم وجنكم قاموا في
صعيد واحد فسالوني
فاعطيت كل واحد
مسالته ما نقص ذلك مما عندي الا كما ينقص
المخيط اذا ادخل البحر يا عبادي انما هي
اعمالكم احصيها لكم ثم اوفيكم اياها فمن
وجد خيرا فليحمد الله ومن وجد غير ذلك فلا
يلومن الا
نف الله سبحانه
وتعالى سبحانه وتالى
‏to place to hide the
tru and to
place the
thing
place as
take
الله
among serv
ان قران الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله الله سبحانه وتعالى
لعب سبحانه
[Silence]
وتعالى
ح
ابوذر صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
حديث my all are
[Silence]
‏all
are my
[Silence]
‏har
‏any
ان شا
الله ظ
حديث الله سبحانه
وتالى
حديث all
‏all stand together in one place and ask
of me and i to give anyone what he
requested then that would not decrease
what
i except what is decreased from the
ocean when a needle is dipped into
it oh my servants it's you but your
deeds
والظلم نوعان ظلم العبد لنفسه
وعظمه الشرك بالله عز
وجل حين
قال سبحانه وتعالى ان الشرك لظلم
عظيم لان الشرك في حقيقته
هو جعل المخلوق في منزله الخالق فهو وضع
الاشياء في غير
مواضعها ثم يليه ارتكاب المعاصي على
اختلاف اجناس من كبائر
وصغائر فكل ذلك من ظلم العبد
لنفسه بايراد موارد العذاب
والهلس التوفيق في الدنيا
والاخره ونضع الموازين القسط ونضع
الموازين القسط ليوم القيامه فلا تظلم نفس
شيئا وان كان مثقال حبه من خردل اتينا بها
وكفى بنا
حاسبين اما النوع الثاني من انواع الظلم
فهو ظلم الانسان لغيره باخذ حقه او
الاعتداء عليه في بدنه او ماله او عرضه او
نحو ذلك وقد وردت نصوص كثيره من السنه
النبويه تحذر من الوقوع في هذا النوع من
ذلك ق قوله صلى الله عليه وسلم في خطبته
في حجه الوداع ان دماءكم واموالكم
واعراضكم عليكم حرام كحرمه يومكم هذا في
شهركم هذا في بلدكم
هذا ظلم
‏ty
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى ان الشرك لظلم
عظيم شك ان الله سبحانه
[Silence]
وتعالى الدن
ظ
الله ظف
[Silence]
الله
‏destruction and
mid
commit the
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتعالى ونضع الموازين القس ليوم
قيامه
قران سبحانه
وتالى seed is that would
be
sign against
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
صلى
عليهل ح خ صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏take one
another just like
we شهر الله
المحرم
الح حرام
بيت الله
المحرم
ح ولا بد ان يكون معلوما عند المسلم ان
الاسلام دين الرحمه حفظ الحقوق كلها للناس
جميعا على شتى اطيافهم واختلافاتهم فكان
تحريم الظلم بين العباد من اعظم المقاصد
التي جا جاءت الشريعه تقريرها فمن جمله
الحقوق التي حفظها الله انه حفظ حق حق
الضعيف والمظلوم وحث على اغاثه ودفع الظلم
عنهم اعلم ا اما بس سعود في
الحديث عن ابراهيم التيمي عن ابيه قال قال
ابو مسعود البدري كنت اضرب غلاما لي
بالصوت فسمعت صوتا من خلفي اعلم ابا مسعود
يقول فلم افهم فلم افهم الصوت من الغضب
فلما دنى مني فاذا هو رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم فاذا هو يردد اعلم ابا مسعود
اعلم ابا مسعود يقول فالقيت الصوت من يدي
فقال اعلم ابا مسعود لا الله اقدر عليك
منك على هذا
العبد ذا الله اقدر عليك منك على هذا
فقلت يا رسول الله هو حر لوجهك لوجه الله
قال اما لو لم
تفعل للفحتك النار او او لمستك النار
[Silence]
ش
‏not only
[Silence]
‏exp have some under you in ter
regard and you have power over them to
press them and you do even makes
the makes thee
wor ابو مسعود البدر
[Silence]
مسعود صلى الله عليه
وسلم
مسعود الله
[Silence]
‏over he said i turned back and i said
prophet he is free for the sake of
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم would been touched the
fire if you not
ابع
ابع ابع
صلى الله عليه وسلم ابو
مسعود في هذا الزمان كلنا ابو مسعود وما
كان ربك نسيا بارك الله لي ولكم في القران
العظيم ونفعني واياكم بما فيه من الايات
والذكر الحكيم اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر
الله لي ولكم فاستغفروه انه الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على المبعوث رحمه للعالمين اللهم صل وسلم
على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اللهم وارضى عنا وعنهم اجمعين ما جاء في
سنن ابن ماجه قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم كيف يقدس الله امه لا يؤخذ لضعيفهم
من شديدهم وقوله صلى الله عليه وسلم ان
الله لا يقدس امه لا يعطون الضعيف منهم
حقه رواه الطبراني
فالاسلام جاء بحفظ الحقوق كلكل جاء بحفظ
حقوق كل فئات الم ممع وشدد في حق الضعيف
سواء كان الضعيف امراه او يتيما او فقيرا
او مريضا او عبدا مملوكا او شعبا اعزل
معزولا وهذا خير دافع لنا للعنايه بامرهم
هؤلاء بامر هؤلاء جميعا والسؤال عنهم
والاحسان اليهم ودفع الضرر عنهم
ونصرتهم فهذا كله من حق المسلم على المسلم
ومن حق ومن ومن انواع دفع الضرر التي
امرنا الله سبحانه وتعالى ورسوله الكريم
اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاولين
وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاخرين وصل
وسلم على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت
وحين اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد حتى
ترث الارض ومن عليها وانت خير الوارثين
اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين واعلي رايتي
الحق والدين المبين اللهم يا ربنا ويا
مولانا ويا سميع الدعاء يا ذا المن
والعطاء يا حي يا قيوم يا بديع السماوات
والارض ويا رحمن الدنيا والاخره ورحيمهما
اللهم انك تسمع كلامنا وترى مكاننا وتعلم
سرنا وجهرنا وتعلم سرنا وعلانيتنا اللهم
ابرم لنا ولي هذه الامه امرا رشدا تعز فيه
وليك وتذل فيه عدوك ويعمل فيه بطاعتك
اللهم انا نتوجه الى باحب الاسماء اليك
ونسالك ونرجوك ونحن نؤمن انك السميع
المجيب القريب اللهم اصلح احوالنا واحوال
المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم اصلح احوالنا
واحوال المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم اصلح
احوالنا واحوال المسلمين في كل مكان في
غزه والسودان اللهم صن واحفظ اخواننا
المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم ارفع عن
اخواننا اخواننا ظلم المعتدين اللهم ادفع
عن اخواننا كيد الغاصبين اللهم انا نعوذ
بك من شرورهم وندر بك في نحورهم اللهم
اجعل تدبيرهم تدميرا عليهم اللهم اجعلهم
في ضمانك اللهم ادخلهم في امانك اللهم
ابني عليهم سور حمايتك اللهم حطهم برعايتك
اللهم احرسهم بحراك اللهم ادفع عنهم ودافع
اللهم ادفع عنهم ودافع اللهم اجعل هذا
المجتمع سخاء رخاء وسائر بلاد
المسلمين بخير وعافيه وسلام واطمئنان
وامان يا رب العالمين اللهم اغفر لنا
خطيئتنا وجهلنا واسرافنا في امرنا وما انت
اعلم به منا اللهم اغفر لنا خطانا وعمدنا
وهزلنا وجدنا وكل ذلك عندنا اللهم اغفر
لنا ما قدمنا وما اخرنا وما اسررنا وما
اعلنا انت المقدم وانت المؤخر وانت على كل
شيء قدير اللهم اجزي وال والدينا عنا خير
الجزاء وبارك لهم في اعمالهم واعمالهم تم
لنا ولهم بخاتمه الاحسان اللهم ومن توفيته
منهم فارحمهم واغفر لهم وافسح لهم في
قبورهم مد بصرهم اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم اللهم احينا على سنته
وامتنا على ملته واوردنا حوضه واكتب لنا
شفاعته اللهم اجز سيدنا محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم خير ما جزيت نبيا عن امته اللهم
اجزي عنا سيدنا محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
خير ما جزيت نبيا عن امته اللهم لك العتبه
حتى ترضى ولا حول ولا قوه الا بك عباد
الله ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء
ذي القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر
والبغي يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون واخر دعوانا ان
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي
على الصلاه حيا على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
استقيم اعتدل استو سو الصف سد
الخلل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين قل
انما
انذركم
بالوحي ولا يسمع
الصم
الدعاء اذا ما
ينذرون ولئن مستهم
نفحه من عذاب رب
ليقولن
ليقولن يا
ويلنا
ان كنا
ظالمين ونضع الموازين القسط ليوم
القيامه فلا تظلم
نفس
شيئا وان كان مثقال حبه من خرد
اتينا
بها اتينا بها وكفى بنا
حاسبين ولقد اتينا موسى وهارون الفرقان
وضياء
وذكرا وذكرا
للمتقين الذين يخشون
ربهم بالغيب
وهم من الساعه
مشفقون وهذا ذكر مبارك
انزلناه
افانتم له
منكرون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين ونفخ في الصور ذا
يوم
الوعيد
وجاءت كل
نفس معها
سائق
وشهيد لقد كنت في
غفله من
هذا فكشفنا عنك غطاءك
فبصرك اليوم
حديد وقال قرينه هذا ما لدي
عتيد القيا في
جهنم كل كفار
عنيد من ناع للخير
معتد
مريب الذي جعل مع الله اله
اخر
فالقياه في العذاب
الشديد قال قرينه ربنا ما اطغيته
ولكن كان في ضلال
بعيد قال لا تختصموا لدي وقد قدمت
اليكم بالوعيد
ما يبدل القول لدي
وما انا
بظلام
للعبيد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏ja
‏komm